we can see on screen okay perfect thank
you very much so let's go over the
curriculum what is planned for uh
plan for getting started with uh
bioinformatics in python
and uh and then also in r uh so you will
start by uh
by getting an introduction to big data
informatics like uh um
you will get an introduction to uh how
to use the platform and how to use
different sections of the platform like
uh you will start with absolute basics
like um how can uh like a couple of
links to install python in your computer
for example or what is a
general ide or uh
interactive development environment or
the wii
that you can use
to
use along with the python
so that you can code
in a more user-friendly manner
and
and you will also learn how to uh for
example
uh
uh perform couple of uh
analysis like couple of exploratory
analysis like as i men as i had
given an introduction to like a box plot
or like a scatter plot etcetera etcetera
in the first session and then we will
slowly start working uh towards
increasing the complexity of of um
understanding how you can use python to
load biological data like uh to load
dna sequence data and how you can for
example
convert the dna sequence into rna
sequence or dna sequence into protein
sequence or how we can get a
display or how you can make a multiple
sequence alignment display
using ah python and how you can perform
for example um
a very basic uh sequence comparison
analysis using two different
dna strings so
this will not only give you some of the
necessary
functions that you will
need to work with python for
bioinformatics data but it will also
give you
how or how generally uh
how python is uh used and what are the
different tools in python is and that
are used for bioinformatics analysis for
dna sequence analysis and etc
so you will again then proceed towards
exploratory analysis where you can
make changes to the data to the
organization of the data that is data
wrangling and you can pre-process the
data which is absolutely necessary
for
for different statistical analysis
and you can perform exploratory analysis
you can perform
visualization of
different exploratory analysis and
using
log transform data for example or using
combined pooled data or using a subset
of your data set so all of these methods
will come under data wrangling and
visualization and then we will also
help you uh
generate or understand different uh
dimensionality reduction uh tools like
uh plots like using principal component
analysis
can be used to visualize the
pattern that that is present in your
data so um so this will be your third
session where you will straight away
start working with
with the structured data
to understand the patterns to generally
understand the pattern
that underlies or that is hidden inside
the data
and then you can go one step higher or
one step more complex by trying to
compare different subsets or different
samples sets of the data that you have
or structure data that you have so these
comparisons can be performed by
um
by by
with the use of a
t-test or
differential gene expression analysis or
different
clustering or unsupervised machine
learning methods like clustering and
hierarchical clustering and k means
clustering and all of these will
help you
differentiate multiple sample types for
example in the data or multiple uh
data types or different phenotypical
types that are
reflected in the distribution of the
data that we are analyzing this data can
be uh
i mean for example uh transcriptomics
data
this data can be meta genomics data and
etcetera different different types of
data will also be
discussed and what we are going to gain
from these different types of data and
what we are going to understand from
analyzing these different types of data
will also be discussed so um and you can
expand your uh
knowledge of bioinformatics knowledge in
python to apply that to various other
types of data and
so then we will we will then
go or we will then
go to or
learn about machine learning tools like
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning tools and
algorithms that are generally used for
biological data
big data mixed data and
you will also be
introduced to or you will also be
explained on different parameters and
settings that are that one needs that
one needs to account for when you are
using different supervised and
unsupervised algorithms like um
how you can set up for supervised
algorithm supervised machine learning
analysis and how what you can actually
gain uh
from from the output of supervised and
unsupervised analysis and how you can
for example um
evaluate the performances of
unsupervised machine learning methods
and supervised machine learning methods
etc that you can
that will also be discussed and you will
also be um introduced to a few
a couple of introductions to predictive
models using deep learning methods also
so you can also use dimensionality
reduction uh with deep learning and we
will also share you uh some coding
lessons that will
help you update that will give a brief
introduction to
deep learning methods and how it can be
applied to
big data
big data
that is generated from high throughput
sequencing
so uh
in the end of this
bioinformatic interactive bioinformatics
in python uh you will also
be introduced to different
projects
that uses or
that uses
python environment for
detailed downstream analysis like
in meta genomics or in
machine learning so you will be
introduced to do uh these example
projects like what was the original aim
uh that was um that the
research article intended to perform
with the data and uh what is a part of
their data that we are considering and
what what is the hypothesis that we are
setting up and what is the
different methods that we are going to
uh employ to
verify or to understand the patterns
within the data and
different steps and different analysis
tools that is necessary to perform these
analysis and
once this analysis is performed and how
you can relate and the characteristics
and how you can implicate
biological understanding from the
research